we are on track for another record month
in terms of participation on our reddit
discussion forum this has grown now to
nearly 2,200 of our viewers and
listeners participating story
suggestions political discussions guests
suggestions it's all happening at david
pakman.com slash reddit i would love it
if you participated i want to go through
some of the more interesting and quirky
and funny discussions from the last week
on the reddit discussion forum starting
with a thread called Trump Russia and
4chan which looks at the alleged
connection between the message board
4chan and the recent alleged blackmail
file by Russia of Donald Trump and it's
a conversation that I've been keeping a
close eye on because there's a lot of
interesting ideas about how the rumors
started swirling regarding the origins
of the supposed blackmail file check
that out also on our reddit discussion
forum a very good post about the
importance of correlation not equaling
causation and when I've talked generally
about reporting on science and medical
studies one of the caveats we have to
bear in mind is that just because two
markers are correlated doesn't mean that
there is a causal relationship and
there's a very very it's funny and
enlightening post about this on our
reddit discussion forum with some
examples of correlations that have no
causal relationship whatsoever yeah it's
one of those logical fallacies that you
have to keep your eye on absolutely also
from our reddit discussion forum a
discussion about Dylan roof being
sentenced to death of course Dylan roof
the convicted shooter in that South
Carolina Church attack from to at 2015
and we had a discussion on the bonus
show about our thoughts on the death
penalty being applied to Dylan roof in
spite of the fact that I am against the
death penalty and there's a really good
follow-up discussion on the reddit
discussion forum which I encourage you
to participate in we also had a
conversation about not watching the
Donald Trump inauguration there's
there's actually sort of a cache
movement about people who are just
saying I can't stomach it I'm just not
going to watch it but also people like
Robert Reich have put out a Robert rice
I always forget how i think is Robert
Bryce yeah Robert rice saying we should
coordinate not to watch the inauguration
and that'll really bother Trump because
of his ego if he finds out he had the
lowest rated inauguration in history
that that would really be a blow to his
ego and there's a discussion on on the
reddit discussion forum about who will
or won't be walking the inauguration and
lastly from our reddit discussion forum
this week a suggestion that I insert
myself in the middle of niche wedge
issues where both sides go crazy and
there's a reference made to when we
jumped into the middle of game Brigade
and basically angered everybody this is
about a year and a half ago and some
suggestions that I jump into for example
interviewing a female genital mutilation
proponent I don't know how many there
are in the US or that speak English that
we could get I'm willing to do that I
just don't know if we can find some one
tab yeah there's probably not too many
but that suggestions not off the table
also the idea of interviewing someone
who doesn't want people using the
bathroom that aligns with their gender
identity we interviewed for a former
navy chaplain gordon clinging schmidt
who's against that and yeah it was
insane but i don't know how much more
there is to learn about that so just a
sampling of the discussions from our
reddit discussion forum i encourage you
to participate in pat and i check it on
a regular basis participate in the
discussions we get story ideas you can
subscribe free at david pakman.com slash
reddit that is our ed DIC